[Musique]
montfermeil l'abcès en seine saint denis
la cité des bosquets
neuf mille habitants plus d'un tiers de
jeunes 95 % d'origine étrangère 36
nationalités
plus de la moitié des chômeurs de la
commune
[Musique]
parmi les fléaux la drogue et les
ateliers clandestins
pour ces jeunes là rien sauf un centre
de loisirs jeunesse animée par des crs
monsieur toutim ezzahi roi en
délicatesse avec la mairie une s'occupe
de sa propre initiative des jeunes des
bosquets
ben voilà
ici c'est que disney jeanne c'est la
frontière rester debout les vab a donc
de ce côté ces sont les riches et des
hypothèses ce sont les fausses alors
pour eux le bosquet c'est une entité à
part qui n'a rien à voir avec ont fermé
ouais mais là il n'y a aujourd'hui et
dans ce cas là parce qu'il y en a qui
lisent londres ok ahizoune pas parce que
quand on voit parfois notre eau
on filme pas on dérange pas
il faut partir on nous dit il faut faire
partie il faut pas cibler voilà c'est
pourquoi mais c'est parce que depuis
longtemps c'est bon le média c'est
toujours en leur défaveur
c'est à dire montre toujours du mauvais
côté des bosquets alors que le bosquet
eu aussi de bons côtés
il ya de jeunes qui se débrouille très
bien c'est à dire légalement en
travaillant depuis d'autres qui font des
études
mais ce côté là on n'a jamais montré
c'est la raison pour laquelle bon il est
pas des journalistes mais comme j'étais
dégoûté de dire sur ce point software
bon c'est un peu gênant non enfants
c'est comme ça ici la voix de moscou
[Musique]
réunion ce soir avec le commissaire
d'andrea de l'aer a pesté pour arrêter
les agressions contre les autobus
ils tentent depuis des mois dédé est de
distraire les jeunes des bosquets en
vain les incidents ont recommencé
ils sont d'accord ya un débat est
tranquille un par un qui parle les
hautes écoles
on est bien d'accord sinon c'est pas la
peine au sort tous on ferme la porte on
est d'accord
bon au reste on qui voit là qu'est ce
qu'on fait en faire la peau alors quand
on est là pour essayer de trouver des
solutions aux problèmes des gros seins
parce qu'il se trouve que il y a des
gens de bonne volonté qui veulent faire
quelque chose on va voir ça bon que le
débat quand mandela
c'est le seul moyen on est là pour
parler de financement d'argent en effet
ya de l'argent si t'as pas sur un patin
je ne pardonne pas pour l'association va
être fermé ok bon balle et parce que ça
va continuer comme ça au lieu d'être
avec monsieur tutti venir 60 rames de
casser les et à brasser si les maires
plus d'argent
mais les gars et les gars du bassin de
la ruhr ont pas dire ça à udine nord sas
et daf les autres il peut être
dangereuse à vous dire pourquoi parce
que vous savez fort bien que chez vous
savez fort bien qu'il faut pas dire
détails parce que même en plaisantant je
vois très bien le mix à insectes et je
sais que votre prépare en plus mais si
d'aventuré il y en a qui ont livré parce
que vous jouez à intelligent et excité
vous savez fort bien ce qui se passera
c'est que des machinistes et bien
montrant plus jusqu'au bousquet puis
vous n'aurez plus de buts pour la ratp
le problème les qualités pour que
justement les réunions il ya toujours
des mêmes paroles c'est comme un genre
de la problème avec le corbeau et le
renard
il parle il fallait l'andorre c'est bien
tard mais le truc quitterait la saignée
moindres comme ça bon là on a des
preuves et là c'est bien beau il ya la
caméra et où vous sortez des belles
paroles qui ferait pas mieux
ils étaient partis comprennent pas tout
le monde
choisir un métier c'est important alors
ce que nous allons essayer de faire
c'est qu'ici on va venir avec des
représentants du bâtiment notamment des
plus on va les visites et d'écoles vont
voir ce qu'on y fait une école de
formation b sera pas une école
traditionnelle et puis peut-être que
vous allez rester une après midi avec
des jeunes qui travaillent là bas pour
pouvoir dialoguer pour dire ben pourquoi
j'ai choisi ce métier plutôt qu'un autre
ainsi ça vous donnera une idée ou est ce
que c'est que la vie professionnelle je
suis pas le mec est à 17 ans j'avais 23
ans là où c'est vraiment du boulot n'est
pas de vous dire que ça peut arriver à
barr montfermeil montfermeil on les a
travaillés c'est foutu mais ces campeurs
français qui est là maintenant ils sont
venus ils sont tous inscrits chez eux
dormir
le vrai problème c'est nous
un autre mur parce que les gens comme ça
a bougé dans une voiture de police et
score puis désormais l'autobus trois
lignes desservent les bosquets comme
ailleurs les machinistes sont souvent
agressés par le fonds de caisse et les
incidents sont fréquents
la dernière il y avait des problèmes
entendu là des gens qui travaillent sont
que je rentre à pied sac à dos
vous
on comprend pas les jeunes qui agissent
comme ça et
c'est difficile quand
on a du mal à s'y faire ans
c'est vrai quand tu
la cites
il ya tout le temps on a tout le temps
pour qu'on en arrive à certains endroits
qui a faim de jeunes on a tout un
sentiment d'insécurité
on devrait pas avoir forcément mai
on a toujours une petite appréhension
tome
chaque fois qu'il ya eu une agression
tous les machinistes ont refusé de
continuer à travailler et de la plupart
du temps entre les voitures quand il ya
agression
machiniste
harry si à chaque fois c'est comme ça
c'est ce qu'ont violence qui monte qui
monte qui monte
[Musique]
la préfecture de seine saint denis à
livry gargan
les employés municipaux de montfermeil
sont venus manifester derrière le maire
pierre bernard heger en 83 le premier
maire de droite
une municipalité communiste depuis la
libération quelques jeunes des bosquets
l'ont suivi le maire vient protester
contre l'insécurité
plus municipal qui a été emmené son
enfant à l'école paul eluard c'est bien
ça il y a il a été agressé par deux
africains benoît et qui leur dit tu nous
donnes 50 francs notre police municipale
qui est un monsieur assez corpulent je
prends un simple en renfort au congrès
pour résoudre et 50 francs et pour toute
réponse un des africains sorti un cutter
et il a cisaillé de l'oreille tu sais
qu'elle allait il est évidemment
concerné en tant que ses insécurités dur
si on s'en prend au personnel communal
le personnel communal ne pourra plus
remplir ses missions dans les services
publics les écoles liste des stades
donc il faut maintenant on connaît ses
forces une une sécurisation et pont de
france entière ça me vient espèces
d'abcès écouter ici est un abcès parmi
400 abcès en france parmi 400 abcès
enfance et je demande que cet accessoire
reconnu et qu'enfin on puisse régler le
problème
non pas le problème de montfermeil enfin
si le problème de montfermeil mais le
plus grave problème si on relève mme
hebel
c'est que vaille le savent pas mais on
ne fait pas tout pour qu'il n'en finir
mais au contraire ça fait 17 ans que je
travaille non seulement je le savais
mais je les écris elle vous l'avez écrit
je les cubains
l'ennui c'est que trop souvent ils
veulent rester eux-mêmes entre eux et ne
pas sortir de leur mosquée mais c'est
peut-être qu'il faudrait accepter
ailleurs c'est possible c'est possible
mais on ne savait pas si beau s'être
bien eh ben les gens comment il me
regarde je me sens pas bien je me sens
sale c'est comme ça et c'est moche vous
avez la réputation d'être en mer à 6
c'est là les gens sachent que les médias
voilà ma réponse fort lee c'est ce que
j'ai écrit et qu'on puisse me liger
lisez ce que j'écris ouvert les yeux la
question jeudi la réputation et monsieur
bernard le maire de montfermeil c'est
d'être ainsi julpan que vous les
meilleurs et puis tu regardes les écoles
qui sont ses pensées vous bien géré a
buté sur le cabinet de la [ __ ] me
charles masséra travail dans les
hauteurs des parties ne vous avez coupé
conçu pour répondre à votre question de
nous des chasseurs pour une histoire
montée par des médias avec l'aide
d'ailleurs je ne dis pas
6 madame je suis catholique pratiquante
dans la religion il n'y a pas de racisme
et d'une deuxièmement je suis ancien
officier de carrière des troupes
coloniales je précise bien des troupes
coloniales aller chercher un officier à
6,6 à trouver un
vous me l'emmener mais on dit qu'on dit
compostelle
j'essayais de faire le choix des gens
qui n'étaient pas là comme ça cher à m
vérifie effectivement il était la police
[Musique]
montfermeil ne se résume pas à
l'affrontement sans merci entre le
conseil municipal et la cité des
bosquets
les deux tiers des habitants
propriétaires de leur villa de leur
pavillon voudrait vivre tranquille et
faire mentir la réputation de leur ville
monsieur et madame gilles habite depuis
27 ans la rue des iris ils sont à la
retraite
avec leurs amis la conversation est
souvent la même certainement quelque
chose à faire pour pourquoi nous
n'avions pas peur avant et pourquoi nous
avons peur aujourd'hui est bien là un
problème quand même pour prendre le
maillot par sierra si c est trop
d'immigrés à m'enfermer comme monsieur
dit pour mettre ailleurs pourquoi vous
avez des banlieues où il y en a un pour
cent même des villes proximité de
montfermeil qui n'ont que 3 % d'immigrés
c'était pas normal ça pourquoi la
bâtisse et des tôles
pourquoi et pourquoi on y envoie tous de
tous et tous ces immigrés vous savez par
exemple nous avons malgré balle dans la
rue bon bah lui il est intégré à 100% ça
c'est certain
tout le monde lui dit bonjour et du
bonjour à tout le monde puisque
maintenant que il lui arrive à quelque
chose tout le monde de défendre et mais
oui c'est un peu c'est un peu comme une
mayonnaise
quand vous verser de l'huile à goutte à
goutte vous remuez ça s'apprend mais là
il y en a trop alors qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire un brassage de population
il faudra les répartir les bosquets il
faut abattre des bars et partager les
immigrés ils sont là on est obligé de
les garder en france peut-être je ne
sais pas c'est pas mon problème ça mais
à montfermeil nous en avons trop il faut
il faut foulée mélenchon je présume
qu'un commerçant car a été cambriolé
plusieurs fois à pic a eu sa vitrine de
casser plusieurs fois un jour ou l'autre
risque de les attendre avec son fusil
c'est certain et puis même dans les
particuliers vous savez quand vous avez
les
vol de postes de radio dans les voitures
et ainsi de suite
c'est à peu près certain qu'un jour ou
l'autre si ça continue ça reste que tu
n'as vraiment vous n'avez vous pensez
avoir une arme bien oui j'y répondrai
s'attaquer dans la rue messi rentre chez
moi je me laisserai pas faire ça c'est
certain
vous en avez eu à comme beaucoup oui
retour au bosquet de l'autre côté du
boulevard
moi je suis je pense à dangereuse je
sais de la tout moment ça peut exploser
et que la caméra même pour en bénéficier
pour comprendre le moment car il faut
connaître trois points fondamentaux
le premier je crois que c'est celui de
la désorganisation vu l'état de
dégradation de la cité de la plupart des
cités de transit ou désenclaver think
l'état des couloirs des ascenseurs des
caves qui son terme et du manque de
loisirs pour les jeunes la pauvreté et
comme je disais tout à l'heure la misère
même dans ce genre de quartier explique
la désorganisation de la cité et c'est
aussi pour quelles raisons les jeunes
aspirent à à devenir délinquants
la rage c'est un sentiment de révolte
que tu peux pas contrôler et qui te
dépasse même
non seulement il dépasse la rigueur
n'est même pas suivi par un autre
mouvement social qui serait derrière ils
croient plus en rien encore plus tôt pis
d'un ancien monde où tous les meilleurs
et tous n'en sont qu'aux plus à ça alors
qu'on devait s'occuper des jeunes vient
calmer
bon tant que c'est possible de les
calmer parce que d'ici un an aussi
manque demain matin ils vont perdre
confiance quand ils vont se révolter et
vont exploser une fois et pour tout ça
sera vraiment la guerre du golfe ma part
le pire que la guerre du golfe parce que
les mecs ici c'est des kamikazes
ils en ont rien à [ __ ] tellement
qu'ils veulent pas les aider
les mecs ça fait quatre ans six ans
qu'il est au chômage et il l'a rappelé
qu alors il va exploser propose
ordinaire un soir d'hiver en banlieue
près de paris
[Musique]